[Musique]
bonsoir à toutes bonsoir à tous merci
d'être avec nous sur TV 78 nous sommes
le mercredi 10 janvier voici le
programme de ce soir et si vous
profitiez des soldes divhivers qui ont
commencé aujourd'hui pour vous équiper
face au froid c'est l'idée qu'on eu
certains yvelinois doudoun chaussures
gants pour contrer les températures
négatives de ces derniers temps ils
deviennent primordiaux et l'année 2024
sera marquée par plusieurs événements la
rédaction de tv78 vous propose un
récapitulatifs des moments phares à ne
pas manquer avec évidemment les gios de
Paris 2024 où plusieurs épreuves se
dérouleront dans les evelines mais aussi
les rendez-vous culturels et les grands
chantiers qui vont se dérouler dans le
département et a failli disparaître mais
il revient à la mode depuis quelques
années le vinyle à la côte auprès des
plus jeunes àonflant saint-honorine
Arnaud George propose de nombreux
disques vintage mais aussi les dernières
nouveautés et puis comme d'habitude
l'invité du 78 en 2è partie d'émission
tout au long du mois de janvier les
maires de 50 ans Eveline viennent
présenter les grands projets de l'année
2024 dans leur commune ce soir Grégory
garestier le maire de morpa sera avec
nous voilà pour le programme de ce soir
avec moi en plateau Gabriel Gontier
bonsoir bonsoir matine journaliste de la
rédaction de tv78 vous allez nous
présenter les informations à retenir
aujourd'hui dans les ivelines on va
parler du froid je suppose oui on va
parler du froid mais ça s'améliore
Mathilde avec la levée de la vigilance
orange neigeeverglas dans les ivelines
on parlera également d'un mouvement de
greffe qui a lieu au lycée Jean Rostan
de Mantel jolie où les professeurs sont
en grève après la réception de menac de
mort envers une professeur du lycée et
donc on fera le point avec vous dans
quelques instants dans l'actualité
aujourd'hui également les soldes divers
qui débutent qui ont débuté ce matin et
avec le froid certains ivelinois en
profitent pour s'équiper en vêtement
chaud Patrick Jacques de dixmud et
Aurélie lafeille ont bravé les
températures glaciales pour vous
demander comment vous comptiez braver le
froid lutter contre le froid depuis 3
jours les températures sont descendues
dans le négatif surpris par les flocons
les ivelinois s'équipent pour affronter
le froid rien de mieux qu'une paire de
gants des collants et une polaire avec
l'arrivée des soldes d'hiver plusieurs
magasins affichent des réductions sur
les vêtements chauds et certains
habitants des Yvelines ont décidé d'en
profiter avec des ressentis jusqu'à Mo-
5°gr le grand froid va se poursuivre
jusqu'à la fin de la semaine pour
l'instant on va à l'essentiel avec le
froid qui est qui est là on lui achète
des gants j'attends un peu de voir si ça
va descendre avec les autres des marques
qu'est-ce que tu vas faire là des
bonhommes de neige et peut-être balancer
des boules de neige sur maman moi demain
que je commence au taf et bah vu les
températures qu' qu' annoncent je je
m'équipe d'accord je me suis pris un un
sous un sous pantalon et puis un un pull
bah un blouson et des gants enfin une
seule paire de gants parce que il y en
avait pas d'autres et pas du solde on a
fait la la réserve de cachcou mes gamins
vont au ski pour le collège et donc j'ai
attendu quand même les soldes pour le
acheter ce qui manquait quoi et les
soldes divhers se poursuivent jusqu'au 6
février si vous comptez faire des bonnes
affaires allez c'est l'heure à présent
de faire le point sur les informations à
retenir aujourd'hui dans les
Yvelines et donc c'est avec vous Gabriel
Gontier on commence avec la levée de
l'alerte neige verglat dans les ivelines
oui maintenu jusqu'à ce midi l'alerte
orange neigeevergl a bien été levée dans
les ivelines aujourd'hui le département
passe ainsi en vigilance jaune si la
situation s'améliore la prudence reste
de mise attention notamment au risque de
chute sur les sols encore verre glacés
par endroit prudence également sur les
routes et à Mantel jolie les professeurs
du lycée jean- Rostan sont en grève oui
depuis lundi tous les enseignants du
lycée se sont mis en grève ils dénoncent
leurs conditions de travail et
l'insécurité qui s'installe depuis
septembre dernier fait en date au mois
de décembre où une enseignante
d'histoire géographie de l'établissement
a été placé sous protection par
l'académie de Versailles cette dernière
avait reçu des menaces de mort et son
domicile avait été recouvert de tag
depuis le début de l'année scolaire de
nombreux incidents s'étaient déjà
produits dans l'établissements comme des
jets de pierre des départs d'incendie ou
encore des menaces envers le personnel
et ce n'est pas un cas isolé dans les
Yveline en octobre à rouillé une
enseignante du lycée Bascan avait
également reçu des menaces de mort hier
soir avait lieu les vœux du président du
département des Yvelines que faut-il
retenir Gabriel tout à fait Mathilde et
cette année encore les vœux se sont fait
conj conjointement entre le département
des ivlines et celui des ha de scèes la
cérémonie avait lieu au Hara de jardi à
Marne la coquette alors parmi les
personnalités présentes de nombreux élus
mais aussi des chefs d'entreprise et des
sportifs durant son discours Pierre
Bédier est notamment revenu sur la
situation financière du départ je vous
propose qu'onécoute le département est
dans une situation financière
extrêmement difficile parce que nous
avons d'un côté un seul impôt donc nous
ne définissons même plus le taux qui
nous a été laissé par l'État comme un
pourboire cet impôt a un rendement bien
moindre puisquil repose sur l'immobilier
qui est en crise chacun le sait et nous
avons une explosion des dépenses
sociales puisque la société française ne
va pas bien et l'économie ne va pas
aussi bien qu'on voudrait nous le dire
alors malgré la volonté du département
d'impacter au minimum les Yvelinois les
défis vont être nombreux pour l'année
2024 je pense que 2024 va être une année
de combat ça va être une année de combat
combat pour les sportifs pour gagner
leur médailles et puis nous combat les
élus les élus locaux en particulier pour
faire comprendre à ceux qui nous
gouvernent queil ne peut pas y avoir de
démocratie dynamique et de démocratie
qui qui représente exactement les
aspirations des Français sans
décentralisation sans s'appuyer sur les
collectivités locales que sont les
communes et les départements on poursuit
ces informations du jour avec l'attentat
du SuperU de treèb 6 ans après euh ce
l'attentat qui avait coûté la vie à
Arnaud Beltram 6 ans après la femme
sauvée par le gendarme sort du silence
avec un livre intitulé sa vie pour la
mienne oui dans ce livre par paru aux
éditions
ège l'ancienne caissière du SuperU rend
hommage à l'ancien officier des zvelines
qui lui a SAU sauvé la vie le jour de
l'attentat un livre à la mémoire d'un un
homme d'exception comme elle le qualifie
pour rappel Arnaud Beltram avait passé
une partie de sa carrière dans les
ivlines notamment au sein du groupement
blindé de gendarmerie mobile de
Versailles satori aujourd'hui d'ailleurs
mathildeun rue porte le nom du colonel
dans le quartier des chantiers et on
termine ces informations Gabriel avec du
sport et plus particulièrement du volet
avec une défaite en Coupe de France pour
l'Union Sportive de conflan André Z joui
oui hier soir le club du CJ volleyball
qui évolu en élite affronté à domicile
l'équipe de Ligue B 51 volleet pour le
3è tour masculin de Coupe de France les
ivelinois se sont inclinés 3 à0 face au
Picard malgré tout l'équipe a fait une
belle compétition elle avait notamment
remporté ses deux derniers matchs face à
Cannes et à Jaco et bien merci beaucoup
Gabriel Gontier pour toutes ces
informations et comme d'habitude si vous
aussi vous voyez une image ou une
information qui vous a marqué près de
chez vous n'hésitez pas à nous la
partager sur les réseaux socix sociau en
utilisant le hashtag 78
news sport culture loisirs travaux
l'année 2024 s'annonce riche en
événement entre les Jeux olympiques de
Paris 2024 qui s'invite sur le
territoire yvelinois ou encore les
grands chantiers de l'année dans le
département voici une sélection des 10
événements importants pour l'année à
venir c'est parti en 3 minutes top
chrono voici les 10 événements
an de 2024 dans les Yvelines en sport la
Course au Soleil parinis partira pour la
15e année consécutive des Yvelines le 3
mars les coureurs s'élanceront des
muraux le lendemain ils partiront de
toiri qui succédera à pogachar le
vainqueur de l'an dernier réponse début
mars c'est l'événement politique de
l'année 2024 l'Europe aux urnes les
élections européennes auront lieu le 9
juin au total 720 députés européens
seront élus donc 81 pour la France au
mois de juin également il soufflera
comme un air d'Interville du côté de
Rambouillet l'agglomération organise ses
premières Olympiades entre les 36
communes de son territoire tir à la
corde pétanque basket ou encore
fléchette les inscriptions sont encore
ouvertes des Olympiades pour se mettre
dans l'ambiance des Jeux olympiques et
paralympiques de Paris 2024 3 jours
avant la cérémonie d'ouverture la flamme
olympique sera de passage dans les
Yvelines dans huit communes une centaine
de porteurs yvelinois participeront à ce
relais jusqu'au domaine de Madame
ellisabeth à Versailles pour l'allumage
symbolique et vous l'aurez compris c'est
l'événement de l'année 2024 pendant un
mois les ivelines vont accueillir
plusieurs disciplines des Jio Versailles
va recevoir les épreuves d'équitation de
paraéquitation et de pentathlon modne
dans le parc du château le vélodrome
national va de son côté héberger les
épreuves de cyclisme sur piste et de
paracyclisme à une santé de mètres ce
seront les courses de BMX toujours à 50
ans en Eveline le VTT prendra place sur
la colline d'élancour pour le golf
rendez-vous sur le green national de
guillancour enfin les coureurs du
marathon et les cyclistes sur route
passeront également dans le département
en septembre un site unique en France
devrait également sortir de terre je
vous parle du village 100 % inclusif
Agora à Montini le Bretonneux handicap
cognitif psychique ou physique la
structure assurera la prise en charge de
tous ceux qui souhaitent devenir
autonome feu d'artifice fête foraine
braderie produit du terroir c'est un
incontournable du territoire la foire de
haoudan est l'une des plus anciennes
foires d'Europe avec sa
954e édition un rendez-vous pour goûter
le fameux pâté de Houdan et après la
foire le cirque acrobate clown magicien
il viennent de partout dans le monde
pour participer au Festival
International du Cirque des Mureaux une
date date importante pour les artistes
car en cas de bonne appréciation du jury
ils présenteront leur numéro à travers
le
monde et c'était il y a 3 ans mais ils
seront jugés à partir du 12 novembre 8
personnes sont mises en cause dans
l'assassinat du professeur Samuel paatti
deux seront notamment jugés pour
complicité d'assassinat terroristes
l'infraction la plus lourde enfin en
2024 les bar r de péag vont disparaître
tout du moins sur la 14 au péage de
Montesson et de chamboursy et sur la 13
au péage de bûchelet cependant il faudra
toujours payer mais sur Internet les
barrières seront remplacées par des
porties automatiques qui scanneront les
plaques
d'immatriculation et on poursuit cette
émission avec un spectacle malgré ses
travaux de rénovation le théâtre de
Saint-Quentin en nivelin poursuit sa
programmation à l'extérieur pour ce
début d'année 2024 il propose dès
dimanchees 14 janvier le spectacle et si
tu dansse au château de Breteuil la
directrice de la communication nous dit
tout au micro de Clara de
Frutos et si tu dans c'est un spectacle
à mi-chemin entre théâtre et danse qui
s'inspire du petit pousser et bien avec
et si tu danses la chorégraphe Marion
levvi et l'autrice Mariette Navaro
imagine le petit est devenu grand et si
tu danse c'est un spectacle tendre et
joyeux qui initie les plus petits à
l'invention à la création et permet au
plus grand de renouer avec les pouvoirs
de de
[Musique]
l'imagination le spectacle et situd Dan
sera proposé dans un cadre tout à fait
exceptionnel celui du château de de
Breteuil le fameux château des comptes
de pro deux représentations sont prévues
l'une à 11h et l'autre à 15h30 dans
l'une des belles bâtises du château dans
l'une des dépendances qui s'appelle
[Musique]
l'Orangerie alors c'est la première fois
en effet que le théâre de saant Eveline
programme un spectacle au château de
Breteuil euh c'est un spectacle qui
s'inscrit dans ce qu'on appelle le tsqy
embalade c'est une série de spectacles
itinérants de forme légère que nous
proposons dans dans des lieux non
équipés cette saison nous avons en tout
neuf spectacles TSC y embalade donc qui
vont sillonn l'ensemble du département
des Yvelines ça représente près de 8000
spectateurs et cela touche plus d'une
près d'une trentaine de de communes
ivelinoises les réservations sont
possibles sur le site du Théâtre he
théatreesqy.org navette et proposé aux
spectateurs qui le souhaitent voilà
toutes les infos pratiques sur le site
les enfants de moins de 5 ans ont une
gratuité bénéficie d'une gratuité et à
partir de 5 ans et pour tous le tarif
est est de 12
€. avis au passionnés de vintage et de
musique le vinyle vintage studio de
Conflant saint-honorine propose des
centaines de disques vinyes du plus en
au plus récent mais aussi des
instruments de musique ainsi que des
cours de guitare Régine ralèche et
Julien Leroi sont partis à sa découverte
[Musique]
regardez crépitement notre heureuse si
vous entendez de la musique rue Maurice
Berto à Conflant saint-onorine alors ça
vient probablement du Viny vintage
studio cette boutique c'est le paradis
des mélomans Viny instrument de musique
cours de guitare ou encore concert les
samedi soir ce disquer a ouvert ses
portes il y a 1 an imaginé et conçu par
Arnaud Georg il nous fait la visite j'ai
créé un lieu où on voulait on pouvait
trouver à peu près tout sur la musique
donc vous pouvez à l'entrée de la
boutique avoir tout ce qui est des
Goudies les vêtements au milieu de la
boutique vous avez tout ce qui est Viny
d'occasion qui se trouve au milieu tous
les accessoires pour les instruments
après si ici vous avez tout ce qui est
Viny neuf tout un mural pour les vinyes
neuf et là vous avez aussi tous les
instruments de musique donc guitare
batterie clavier ici au fond et tous les
accessoires nous avons aussi une scène
qui tourne une fois par semaine le
samedi de 18h à 19h vous avez ici euh
chez chez nous deux studios de
répétition sont des studios que je loue
aux groupes qui viennent répéter le soir
essentiellement j'ai beaucoup de groupes
qui viennent répéter le soir de entre
19h et 22h mais la journée ces studios
sont utilisés par des professeurs en
fait vous êtes un peu une boutique et
une école un peu tout quoi voilà c'est
ça en fait pour tout vous dire je
voulais créer un endroit qui me
ressemble et comme j'aurais aimé le
trouver quand j'étais plus jeune et
cette boutique c'était la surprise pour
les conflanés d'autant plus pour les
jeunes qui raffolent des disques vinyes
depuis 7 ans la demande augmente et en
2023 les moins de 35 ans représentent
près de 60 % des acheteurs quand j'ai vu
ça il y a un an une boutique de vinyes
qui ouvre dans ma ville moi j'étais
super content parce que moi j'adore les
vinyes donc là plus besoin d'aller loin
quand s'emb bat de chez soi quoi B mon
fils adore tout ce qui est Viny il il
aime beaucoup la musique bien souvent
ces cadeaux bah c'est ça c'est du Viny
pour pour les anniversaires pour les
fêtes trouve ça cool de pouvoir en
trouver d'occasion plutôt que d'acheter
sur des sites en ayant du neuf donc là
ouais c'est sympa de pouvoir un peu
aussi Yeter en direct et tout ça
quoi alors rgine est-ce que vous avez
trouvé votre bonheur ah bah oui
totalement franchement j'ai trouvé de la
musique haïtienne et
latino-américaine et donc si vous aussi
vous êtes intéressé par des vinyles
sachez que vous pouvez en trouver ici à
partir de 4
€
[Musique]
et c'est bientôt l'heure de passer à
l'invité du 78 mais avant je vous
propose de jeter un coup d'œil à la
météo de
demain demain matin nous devrions avoir
un beau soleil sur l'ensemble des yelin
au niveau des températures elles seront
toujours dans le négatif compte - 4°gr à
Oudan 3 degr à versaill et rouillé et -
1 degr à Mantel jolie l'après-midi le
soleil brillera toujours autant dans le
département et les températures seront
toujours aussi froides il fera 3°gr à
Mantel jolie et 2°gr à Oudan rambouillé
et Versailles pour rappel Météo France
place toujours les Yvelines en vigilance
jaune grand froid et demain nous
fêterons la saint Pauline c'est l'heure
à présent de faire le c'est l'heure à
présent de l'invité
et l'invité du 78 ce soir c'est le maire
de morpa grégoryi garestier bonsoir
bonsoir meilleur vœux meilleur vœux
bonne année 2024 à vous et à tous les
morpasiens et les morpasiennes première
question quel bilan faites-vous de
l'année 2023 je suppose contre
l'inflation mais aussi les émeutes
urbaines ça n'a pas été une année facile
oui c'est vrai ça se cumule alors pas
été assez épargné par par par les
émeutes pour autant 2023 oui a été une
année assez assez compliquée sur le plan
évidemment de l'inflation des coûts
énergétiques de l'inflation également
des coûts sur les ressources humaines
euh au sein de la collectivité puisque
différentes réformes se sont imposées à
nous mais aussi pour le bien-être
j'allais dire de nos de nos agents
publics après une une bonne année pour
Castalia le centre aqualudique
intercommunal avec la ville d'élencour
une vraie réussitein on a déjà les
premiers chiffres sur l'année 2023
250000 entrées donc on en est satisfait
et puis ça montre bien que avec le maire
d'éencour on a mis Jean-Michel frgous on
a eu raison de partir sur un équipement
neuf adapté au besoins d'aujourd'hui et
de demain et je crois que l'équipement a
rencontré son public justement il va y
avoir des nouveautés pour l'année 2024
pour Castalia oui absolument alors le
délégataire est très dynamique propose
un certain nombre de d'actions au
quotidien pour autant il va y avoir des
actions au sur les thèmes des Jeux
Olympiques évidemment c'est
2024 avec toutes sortes d'actions
sportives et d'animation autour des Jeux
Olympiques donc c'est plutôt bien en
plus de de toutes les actions que la
commune elle menera de son côté avec les
écoles les centres de loisirs ou les
associations alors on parlait de
l'inflation on parlait aussi d'un
contexte financier compliqué pour les
communes est-ce que à cause de ce
contexte compliqué vous allez devoir
augmenter les impôts locaux dans votre
commune alors à ce stade ce n'est pas
envisagé on en plein arbitrage
budgétaire nous n'avons pas augmenté les
impôts locaux l'année dernière c'est
compliqué on a dû faire plus d'un
million d'euros d'économie quand même
puisqueon a dû absorber le choc
énergétique l'inflation comme je l'ai
dit sur les coût des ressources humaines
et d'autres d'autres coût on prend par
ex sur par exemple sur tous nos marchés
publics 20 à 30 % d'augmentation de tous
nos coûts donc ce qui n'est pas rien
faut l'absorber on fait des choix on
fait glisser des investissements bref on
a une gestion responsable et rigoureuse
on est très attentif alors dans les
grands projets pour 2024 Grégor
garestier il y a la nouvelle Hal du
marché où en sont les travaux oui et
j'ai l'impression qu'on parle de ce
sujet ça fait 5 ans qu'on a eu
l'incendie criminel absolument ou oui
donc on a perdu du temps avec la covid
on le sait très bien euh et là on a
perdu du temps j'avais annoncé que les
travaux devaient commencer en octobre et
lors de mon dernier Facebook live je
j'ai annoncé au morpasien qu'on avait
perdu quelques mois à cause d'un appel
d'offre infructueux en fait on a des
entpres qui n'ont pas répondu donc on a
dû relancer les appels d'offres donc
c'est C fois-ci on est en pleine
négociation donc j'ai bon espoir que les
travaux commencent d'ici la fin de
l'hiver début du printemps pour une
livraison un ans plus tard en 2025 mais
en tout cas je rassure les morpasiens la
du marché verra bien le jour
elle est attendue une une Hal du marché
moderne 1500 m² avec panneaux solairire
récupération d'eau de pluie des
toilettes publiques ouvertes 7 jours sur
7 24h sur 24 des étales pérennes pour
les commerçants bref une EAL moderne
avec des travaux qui qui vont commencer
bientôt voilà alors dans les autres
travaux de la commune le boulevard
miseré qui va passer en deux fois une
voix c'est là aussi où en sont les
travaux oui alors les travaux avancent
bien donc un projet que nous menons avec
l'agglomération de 5ant1 puisqu'on est
sur un une une voie d'intérêt qu'on
appelle communautaire euh et donc qui
était nécessaire le boulevard miser est
un boulevard qui est surdimensionné avec
8000 véhicules par jour qui était en en
2ux fois de voies alors que le boulevard
de la Loir qui est perpendiculaire était
déjà en deux fois une voie avec 16000
véhicules par jour donc on on repense la
totalité du boulevard contraler pour des
nouvelles places de stationnement pour
aussi déservir le centre médical des
pyramides qui accueillent une
IRM replantation de plus de 115 arbres
et arbustes création d'une noue des
retenu d'au de pluie on refait également
on change les réseau d'eau souterrain on
en profite et on passe à deux fois une
voie en effet et l'objectif c'est aussi
de laisser la place au vélo absolument
oui oui on on élargit les pistes
cyclables et piétones pour les nouvelles
mobilités et puis aussi la sécurisation
des passages pour les collégiens du
collège pergot et du lycée des Semar pas
loin et du Conservatoire alors autre
projet d'envergure concernant concernant
la circulation l'enfouissement d'une
partie de la route nationale 10 au
niveau du carrefour de la malmedonne ça
se concrétise le projet pourrait entrer
en Phe d'enquête publique avant le
printemps 2024 qu'est-ce que ça va
changer pour les habitant de morpa bah
écoutez ça va permettre d' c'est un
projet qui est attendu depuis longtemps
c'est vrai que là on a pu aboutir sur la
répartition financière et sur
l'inscription au contrat de plan état
région ce qui était pas gagné il y a eu
quand même une une lourde négociation et
je remercie également tous nos
partenaires autour de la table pour
faire preuve de plusnacité sur ce
dossier et donc ça va changer le fait
que la départementale 213 va être
réouverte parce qu'elle avait été fermée
dans les années 60 pour accéder
directement à la gare de laavrière donc
c'est un projet qui concerne les villes
de coignère et de laavrière également
donc ça va permettre d'accéder plus
directement à la ger de la
verrière d'éviter aussi de passer par le
centville de morpa par des reports de
flux donc c'est un décaissement
souterrain de la nationalis vous l'avez
dit l'enquête publique commence au
printemps avec des travaux qui
commenceront dans quelques années parce
que c'est un projet assez lourd et très
coûteux puisque aussi il y a le projet
de trappe qui est en cours donc voilà
donc c'est une nécessité pour la
vitalité du secteur pour l'accès à la
gare et surtout pour permettre aussi aux
morpasiens qui souhaitent accéder à la
Guare plus facilement que ce soit à pied
en vélo ou en voiture avec le nouveau
parking relais alors depuis le début de
votre premier mandat en
2014jà vous vous êtes aussi attelé à la
rénovation des nombreux bâtiments
communaux la suite en 2024 c'est quoi la
rénovation des école dans le
centre-ville oui entre autres j'en
profite parce que c'est l'exemple un peu
de Castalia c'est-à-dire que
l'héritage que j'ai eu en 2014 étaaiit
des équipementsuss vetustes euh et qui
datait aussi de la création de la ville
nouvelle et aujourd'hui le fait de faire
le Paris soit de la reconstruction des
restructuration lourde c'est vraiment
l'ambition que je mène avec mon équipe
de préparer l'avenir on a préparé
l'avenir avec le centre acoludique on a
préparé l'avenir avec des écoles qu'on a
rénové et là on poursuit donc on a le
centre de loisir primair qui est au
village qu'on va totalement reconstruire
un équipement qui datait de 1983 qui
n'avait jamais connu de rénovation donc
il valait mieux le détruire pour avoir
un équipement qui soit moderne adapté au
temps d'aujourd'hui au besoins des
animateurs et des enfants puisque ça
fait aussi restauration scolaire ça fait
centre d'accueil périscolaire en plus du
centre de loisirs et un équipement qui
soit tourné vers le développement
durable avec la réglementation re 2020
comme on peut dire un peu techniquement
et aussi les écoles du centrre-ville
donc hautefutet cité centre et la
malmedon c'est à peu près 600 enfants
600 élèves qui sont concernés quand même
euh donc ça représente quel cût euh tous
ces travaux de rénovation alors alors on
est en train de de de terminer les
chiffrages c'est pas encore totalement
abouti parce que euh on a dû faire aussi
clisser un peu dans le temps ces projets
d'investissement qui sont extrêmement
lourds euh on a fait une concertation
auss que les parents d'élève à l'époque
donc on devrait affiner le le le
l'enveloppe budgétaire cette année pour
des travaux je l'espère qui devrai
commencer par l'école de la haute futé
l'année prochaine pour après continuer
sur cité centre et la malmedon c'est
très lourd donc on va prendre notre
temps ça n'empêche pas l'entretien
régulier mais en tout cas ce sont trois
écoles qui en ont besoin d'autant plus
que la haute fut va se transformer va
passer d'une école maternelle à
élémentaire pour décharger celle de la
malmodonne qui est déjà
suffisamment dense avec plus de 300
enfants euh donc voilà on reviendra de
toute façon vers les morpasiens les
parents d'élèves sur ce sujet en courant
2 20 24 mais c'est en train de s'affiner
on avance on avance correctement sur le
dossier alors pour terminer pour
terminer grégoryi garessier il nous
reste environ un peu moins d'une minute
pour votre carte blanche quel sujet
libre souhaitez-vous aborder oui il y il
y a un projet qui me tient à cœur avec
mon équipe euh c'est la création d'un
parc urbain vous le savez on on on
construit du logement pour faire venir
de nouvelles familles on fait du
renouvellement urbain dans la zone
d'activité Paris Ouest en lie et place
d'entreprise soit qui était fermé ou
soit qu'on aide à se déplacer pour
permettre d'accueillir de nouveaux
logements parce que morpa vous le savez
il a des obligations de construction de
logements sociaux mais pas que on y fait
aussi de l'accession libre à la
propriété on y fait du logement
intermédiaire on va tester aussi un
nouveau produit qui s'appelle le bail
réel solidaire pour permettre à des
familles qui ne peuvent pas aller dans
le logement intermédiaire ou dans
l'accession libre de pouvoir accéder à
la propriété avec des logements à 20 ou
30 % moins cher et dans cet écoquartier
décor intarpan nous allons euh sur une
surface de 4000 m Carr il aménager un
parc urbain je tiens à le préciser parce
que aujourd'hui avec la pression
foncière que nous avons euh il est assez
rare de construire des parcs sur des
terrains qui peuvent être constructibles
h et donc là pour la vitalité de la
ville pour aussi garantir son âme
garantir sa qualité de vie le le cadre
de vie des morpasiens et aussi les
nouveaux habitants qui arrivent dans cet
écoquartier l'aménagement d'un parc
paysager que nous allons coconstruire
avec le conseil des jeunes qui a été
créé en 2023 euh qui est une ouveuté
aussi donc avec les 16 membres du
conseil des jeunes on va travailler sur
ce nouveau parc urbain comment voilà
quelle va être l'ambition en terme de
développement durable en terme
d'activité ludique évidemment dans
l'aspect du voisinage c'est toujours la
la problématique mais en tout cas voilà
c'est un projet qui qui nous tient à
cœur et je tenais à en parler ce soir et
bien merci beaucoup
grégoriavoir répondu à notre invitation
encore une bonne année 2024 à Marpa et
c'est la fin de ce 78 merci pour votre
fidélité je vous souhaite une belle
soirée sur tv78 prenez soin de
[Musique]
vous